by the time you watch this video
cyberpunk will be one year old it's been
a long and exhaustive year of problems
in patches cyberpunk to me isn't a great
game but it's also not a bad game either
judging from the amount of videos i've
made on the game when it was released
it's clear that i genuinely liked what
cd projekt red was doing i just feel
that people let the negative aspects of
the game cloud their judgment on content
that deserves actual praise leading to
people saying everything about the game
is horrendous which is just untrue so
today i'll be revisiting cyberpunk once
again and giving it the thorough review
it deserves
let's get started usually i would start
most of these videos with cyberpunk's
first impressions and how it tries to
capture the player's attention but there
are more important things to discuss
first as throughout the release of the
game cyberpunk was criticized for two
specific reasons that being its
technical issues and its lack of
features for its bugs and glitches most
of its consistency revolved around your
platform and your specs i played
cyberpunk on my xbox series x but a
friend of mine played on his day one
xbox one most of the game's bugs at the
time like enemies appearing out of
nowhere or npc's t-posing occurred much
more for him than it did me the other
technical issues were based around your
builds and play style of cyberpunk such
as an issue where your gun would
magically reload every time you swap to
that weapon obviously if you use blades
throughout your playthrough then you
wouldn't experience this problem but
that doesn't mean it didn't exist so to
make this easier i'll just be going over
all the bugs i found during my two
playthroughs then discuss it afterwards
the first problem occurred right in the
beginning of the game during my
corporate life path and it's related to
not being able to answer the phone
thankfully the game answers the call for
you anyway but there were numerous times
i would try to answer the phone and
wasn't allowed to just like it was on
day one this car doesn't load in sync
with the cutscene causing the car to
look untextured i don't know what caused
this next one but apparently if you run
too fast to the helicopter it won't take
off in sync with the player as it's
technically supposed to ascend before
you get up the stairs during the scene
where takamura and v defend themselves
from arasaka soldiers the first guy
actually phases into the game rather
than drives on screen like he should
when doing the side quest where you have
to rescue the surgeon for dennis his
voice changed tones mid dialogue
i know here
may this blade serve you well
right after this i went to clear a few
ncpd assault activities and during
combat my shotgun would just not fire
this continued even after i had switched
weapons surprisingly i had only one
crash which occurred while driving after
talking to makako this next one happened
quite a bit and is definitely player
dependent as numerous times especially
during brain dances the audio would
overlap and then just cut off so the
next line could start stopping people up
they were scrolling xbds
okay
coffee was cold
like
from the day before
people
used to have a bit so
the brain dances in this game are
obviously quite boring after the first
time through so i wanted to finish them
as fast as possible which caused judy
and v to have multiple conversations at
one time the only way to prevent this
from happening is to not go too fast
during the brain dances but obviously
the players shouldn't change their way
of playing just so the problem is fixed
our next bug occurs numerous times where
for no clear reason i couldn't drive in
a certain direction and was stuck this
happened a few times when entering the
all the caldos camp but the game blocks
you on purpose so you don't run everyone
over but in this instance i was just in
the middle of the road nowhere near the
camp immediately after this as i was
approaching the objective the game
stopped me too far and i couldn't
progress the game attempts to slow the
player down so the interaction between v
and panam can start but the game doesn't
stop you on a dime rather breaks for you
the game also relinquishes control of
the vehicle since panama is supposed to
drive right after this so if you go too
fast the game will stop you past the
objective and leave you stuck in the car
until you reload the game onto the more
infuriating bugs the black bar during
the samurai concert still exists and
continues to sour my mood every time
during the mission with takamura and v
where they're at the markets there were
no npcs where i was and to make matters
worse on the way there i somehow got
into combat and this stayed for the
entire mission there was no enemies in
any of these areas so combat should have
stopped immediately but when time was
passing due to waiting or teleporting to
the next part in the quest it still
persisted and of course because i was in
combat the entire conversation was
completely inaudible thanks to the
and
music
man
the strongest man i have ever known
as for the others numerous times even on
release the game would refuse to let you
swap your camera angle forcing you to
drive in first person this perk changed
every time i viewed it until the
description was just incomprehensible
and i also got stuck in the water and
was unable to move at all forcing me to
reset while some of these bugs were
frustrating i couldn't help but laugh at
some like when saul just disappeared
mid-conversation when i caught takamura
t-posing and when my gun was reloading
on its own for no reason if you've been
counting along with the video then you
may have noticed that there were roughly
16 to 17 unique problems i had
encountered during my playthrough
obviously that total number is much
larger as some had occurred more than
once but even more interesting than that
is that 12 of these bugs were new
however this plays into what i said
earlier i didn't use guns in my original
playthrough as that was centered around
blades so the issue related to the
weapons like my precision rifle
reloading on its own could have been in
the game since day one i just never
encountered it till now regardless it's
clear that even after the enormous
amount of patches this game received
there is still work that needs to be
done but this leads me to my next point
as i shouldn't just be focusing on the
bad cd project red did fix many issues
with this game many of them being very
specific so it's quite possible any
issues you had in your previous
playthrough are gone and your game is
now practically bug free this even
happened to me as while i don't recall
all the issues i had with cyberpunk back
then a few notable problems never
occurred during my recent playtime such
as my character not being bald during
the suicide ending being able to see out
of the av during rogue's ending and the
item descriptions not staying stuck on
my screen anymore as for my final
thoughts on this section it's clear that
while cd projekt red fixed lots of bugs
for many players my experience is the
only thing i can go off of your game
could be worse or better than mine
depending on your platform's specs and
the previous issues you've encountered
with the game continuing to introduce
new bugs i had never seen before it
shows that the game is quite possibly
just as bad as it was on launch and
that's not a good sign the last thing to
discuss in this section is cd projekt
red's broken promises this is probably
what bothers me the most about this game
as what i'm about to say makes cyberpunk
sound like a completely different game
on paper a couple months after release a
reddit thread by a user named spikecraft
was started which was a community list
of all the content cd project red had
promised the players this thread is
split into two categories features that
were promised but later cut during
development and features that were
expected on launch but never came the
latter is what i want to focus on more
as the former is not as problematic as
it sounds for example in that section is
the ability to scale walls during one of
the gameplay demos v can be seen scaling
a wall obviously this isn't in the game
but a news article from july 2020 six
months before the launch of the game
stated that this wasn't going to make
the final release so we knew ahead of
time that this wasn't going to make it
to launch due to certain limitations
however everything i'll be stating now
was mentioned in news articles
interviews or videos by cd projekt red
saying that this content would be in the
game and was never followed up on that
it was going to be cut as far as the
community knew this stuff would be in
the game on launch the list will be in
the description down below if you want
to check it out for yourself but it goes
as follows cyberpunk was going to have a
very well developed ai cd project red is
quoted saying we've greatly enhanced our
crowd and community systems to create
the most believable city in an open
world to date the city streets are
bustling with crowds of people from all
facets of life all living their lives of
the full day night cycle it takes three
minutes after stepping out of your
apartment to see that this is completely
wrong police don't drive cars ai will
not attempt to drive around roadblocks
and will have the same animations when
ducking and running away from combat
cyberpunk was going to have a wanted
system where npcs would hunt down the
player and even be able to interact with
corrupt police officers allowing you to
bribe them keeping with the theme of
police they were also going to have a
much larger role in the game's crime
system as certain areas would change
based on the district rich areas like
city center would have had more police
and more run-down areas like pacifica
would have fewer cops allowing you to
get away with more crime the gameplay
was massively tuned down as mono wire
and gorilla arms are supposed to have
more uses like monowire being able to
hack people from a distance the game was
also quoted to have a deeper role
playing system than the witcher 3. it
stated in the 48 minute gameplay
walkthrough that random occurrences like
scavenger's ambushing you would be
possible which we know is completely
false as while this did happen it was
scripted and only happens one time in
the game as for the other promises i'll
file these under a miscellaneous
category quest decisions were going to
have a relevant impact on the story and
the life paths were going to be much
more in depth and would lead to
non-linear quest design
i don't think an explanation is needed
on that there would also be a meaningful
day night and weather cycle that would
make areas more dangerous by either
having more gang members out at night or
storms that will hinder the player
neither of these exist or don't seem to
exist especially the weather as the dust
storm only plays a role in two quests
cyberpunk would also have distinct
styles of clothing and have npcs react
to the clothing you are wearing and
finally while it wasn't stated by cd
projekt red specifically i think it's
quite obvious that it's industry
standard to expect your game to run
smoothly on launch this isn't even all
the stuff in this list i highly
recommend you check out that reddit post
in the description or better yet watch
any video on cyberpunk prior to its
release like the trailers and gameplay
demos and you'll see just how much is
missing from this game i am completely
aware that everything shown was from a
demo build of the game and of course is
subject to change cd projekt red did a
good job of telling us that some of the
content in the game wouldn't make it to
its full release like scaling walls and
vehicle customization so why did they
mention these but not the dozens of
other pieces of content that would be
missing on paper this sounds like a
completely new game in a game i'd much
rather play compared to the one we got
while i do have some issues with the
game itself what i am more upset about
is the content we were promised but
never received as now i feel like a fool
and that's downright embarrassing
while its technical issues are laughably
bad its first impressions were quite
impressive until you look at it a little
more critically then you discover a few
problems before you start the game
you're given the option to customize
your character and choose your abilities
and life path the concept of this is
great and i genuinely liked this game's
customization and starter points but its
life paths were underdeveloped the three
life paths in the game are cool and were
a great idea but you just felt left
hanging once you were done with them the
point of the life paths was to create a
unique experience for the player and
also tell us the player how jackie and v
became friends and how v got into night
city each of these stories is very
unique and with what we were given it
was great i liked how not every life
path had to do with killing people a
theme we'll definitely see later i also
enjoyed how the life paths continued to
play into the role the game was
establishing during the corporal life
path we see v throwing up because of the
stress at work many people in the
corporate world of cyberpunk work
horrible hours and get very little
benefits v ends up taking medications to
calm his nerves and keep him awake and
he even has his own life coach clearly
living this way will make someone very
bitter and angry and the game knows this
is they'll allow you to just outright
ignore people in conversations and blow
them off because work comes first it's a
great representation of the dystopian
lifestyle that the working class face in
night city the other life paths also do
the same but the corporal path really
excels in this department each of them
also do a wonderful job explaining how v
made it to night city for the nomad path
we could see him cross the border while
trying to smuggle in gear for the street
kid path we found out that he left night
city to find a better life but
ultimately never did and ended up coming
back and for the corporal path while it
was never told how we can just assume v
either grew up here or was moved here
because the mega corporation said so as
for the relationship between jackie and
v only the street kid in to an extent
the corporal life path makes sense the
streak hit path ends with jackie trying
to take the same ride as v and they end
up both getting caught and after being
released apologize to each other for
screwing up the job of the other and
through some conversation they find out
that they have lots in common both of
them frequently visit the coyote kojo
and are acquaintances of pepe however
the corporal path doesn't really explain
how jackie and bee know each other other
than the fact that they're just friends
the corporal path can kind of be seen as
a friend helping another friend after
losing his job but it's never explained
how the two met the nomad path bothers
me greatly as the entire mission
revolves around you transporting the
stolen gear across the border with
jackie border security tipped off the
corporation jackie had stolen the gear
from and we have to defend ourselves
after we find a spot to lay low the two
get into a heated argument over it
during this jackie reveals that he
didn't even have the money to pay v for
the job as he was just going to bust our
ass the moment we crossed the border but
he decided not to because we're all
right jackie tries to convince v that he
should stay in night city as the two
have some chemistry together and it's
possible that they could sell the stolen
gear he has and go half seas on it so
jackie the guy who claims v and him have
chemistry together despite that being
completely untrue tells v he will split
the price of the iguana after literally
telling him a minute prior that he
didn't plan to pay him for the job after
hearing all of this v
joins him
how does that make any sense who's to
say that jackie won't split the price 50
50 and skip town again these two are
literal criminals once someone ruins
your trust it's all over especially if
it's a person you are just meeting for
the first time so the fact that v
partners with him is completely idiotic
and is 100 forced onto the player since
they need v and jackie to be friends and
to make it into night city thankfully
the life paths don't just stop here
though as the game will provide the
player with unique missions and
different dialogue options throughout
the playthrough except the dialogue
options don't change anything within the
story as it needs to be accessible to
everyone and the option rarely appears
throughout the game so they barely feel
usable there are more speech checks in
dialogue related to your skills rather
than your life path as for the missions
there is only one mission per life path
and there really isn't much substance
within them anyway it's sad how none of
them truly matter and if we were to get
into the storytelling of the game many
would agree that the street kid is the
only canon option no matter the life
path v becomes a merc and goes into a
life of crime doing jobs for clients
that more than likely result in people
dying this feels like the street kid
path as you're going to fixers and
clients for jobs you aren't living out
in the outskirts of the city smuggling
in gear and you're not contacting people
from your prior employment so it just
feels like v was meant to take the
street kid route this makes the life
paths completely useless as all you're
really getting is a 20 minute
introduction to explain some minor
backstory which leads to the same start
of the game and only gives you one
unique option and a small amount of
opportunities to actually use your life
path background in dialogue cyberpunk's
first impression initially was well done
as it has a robust selection of
customization to make you feel unique
and three life paths that would have
given the player a unique introduction
and backstory to their character
allowing them to build a much deeper
connection to them until they realize
that the life paths are either rushed or
feel forced and are never brought up
again making that intro worthless while
the game does gatekeep the player after
this allowing them to travel only within
watson we can technically start the
optional content of the game i've been a
fan of the cyberpunk aesthetic since i
first discovered 2017's blade runner
2049. it's a world that is overwhelmed
with technology where people are more
likely to have cyber implants in them
than be fully human well on the surface
it sounds great once you dig deeper you
realize what the style is considered
dystopian cd projekt red nails the
setting of this game it feels like a
cyberpunk style city and it checks all
the boxes that a place like this should
have the world is supposed to look great
on the outside but be terrible on the
inside night city is overrun with crime
and is policed by the law that would
rather shoot first and ask questions
later the city itself is free from
government rule which means it's highly
regulated by mega-corporations which is
why arasaka has such a big influence in
the game night city citizens are always
one wrong step away from death as the
gang's police and mega corporations
poach as much as they can out of the
working class besides the groups within
night city the everyday citizen has all
the effects of a highly advanced society
within a cyberpunk world everyone is
below the poverty line with only the
mega corporations having enough money to
survive and with an increase in
production across all industries
pollution and climate change are major
contributors to the city's conditions
cyberware has become a common place
within night city but due to the
aforementioned details faulty black
market cyberware runs rampant and should
someone add too much cyberware to their
body they could develop cyberpsychosis
to combat this the police once again
just prefer to eliminate the psycho
rather than treat them it's very clear
that this world sucks and cd projekt red
does a great job of conveying the
dystopian feeling of the game by
expanding on one of those details cyber
psychos can be found throughout the game
and each of them tell a story about the
people that are living with this illness
i did an entire video back then based on
this exact topic as i felt this was one
of cyberpunk's greatest strengths these
were so different from the other side
activities in the game as you weren't
always shooting at people it was either
about navigating the area they resided
in or scanning around looking for clues
each of these areas usually has a story
along with it whether that be from
shards or the actual mission itself and
all of them are great one encounter was
about someone who was kidnapped and had
implants forcibly put on them another
was about a girl who was tricked by her
sister into getting faulty implants
because she wanted to ruin her sister's
beauty she would then go on to marry her
sister's fiance without her knowing this
already sounds tragic enough for her
until you realize that all the cameras
near the crime scene were from a tv
studio who was filming a reality tv show
they knew about the sisters rivalry and
let the girl know of her sister's
attempt to marry her fiance the studio
did all of this traumatic stuff to her
for just a few clicks and it really
portrays the terrible motivations behind
reality tv probably my favorite was a
random guy on the end of a bridge he's
backed himself into a corner but has
managed to fend off all the police that
have arrived after subduing him you
discover from his laptop that he's a
combat veteran who suffers from severe
ptsd thankfully at his current job there
was a ptsd program that he could enroll
in but he was eventually fired and lost
that privilege leaving him no way to
handle his problems this caused him to
not keep a job causing him to be
homeless due to no income and eventually
led to how we see him in game there are
17 of these encounters in the game and i
can't think of a single one that was bad
each of them portrayed different people
from different walks of life and showed
how they got cyber psychosis and how
they're currently dealing with it it's
truly one of the best groups of side
content in the game which actually makes
me extremely upset as this is
overshadowed by all the other activities
that are some of the most boring content
i've played in a video game besides the
cyber psychos we have gigs and ncpd
hustles the gigs are a toss-up most of
them have the same content and depending
on your build might seem like the same
mission there are a few gigs that are
quite boring but do become very exciting
when you switch your playstyle like this
gig where i needed to take some guy from
this building and put him in the trunk
of a nearby car if i were to shoot the
place up i would just kill everyone then
carry the guy's body out but if i were
to play a sneak character then i would
try to avoid detection by sneaking my
way in like i said depending on your
play style some may feel unique but most
of the time it's the same content the
ncpd hustles however are just awful
there are a few different versions of
them all of which are basically the same
thing you complete the assaults and
progress by either killing all the
criminals and collecting the loot or
looting the crate undetected reported
crimes are beaten by killing all the
criminals in the area then grabbing the
illegally stashed loot an organized
crime is just killing all the criminals
in the area considering the fact that
the game's main gameplay loop is killing
enemies collecting their loot then
replacing your current gear with better
items it's just the same thing you've
been doing in any of the other missions
before this leads to all of these being
incredibly boring i can't recall a
single time i enjoy doing these and it
also showcases something quite unique
that there's no penalty for being caught
if there's an optional stealth objective
that you fail you might miss out on a
bit of rep or money but considering how
many of them there are in the game the
loss is negligible running and gunning
in this game is not only more exciting
but more efficient all you'll really be
doing is going to the location of the
hustle finishing it within two minutes
and then going to the next location
funny enough driving from one hustle to
the next is sometimes slower than doing
the actual hustle itself they're just
lazy and boring activities with a clear
lack of depth and interactivity that are
copy pasted so much it's hard to tell
what activity you're actually doing
speaking of which another example of
poor depth and development is the gangs
and fixers in cyberpunk the gangs and
fixers in this game are incredibly
shallow every district in the city has a
head fixer and a gang that holds the
territory the gangs only exist to be
shot at and the fixers really shouldn't
even be on the map at all all the gang's
backstories and values are incredibly
unique maelstrom is a psycho gang
dedicated to putting in as many implants
as possible and the animals prefer to
use their cyberware to increase their
strength i also believe they're the only
gang in the game that will attack the
player with just their fist the story of
these gangs is incredible but everything
else in game is awful because there is
nothing else on rare occasions you can
work with certain gangs like the voodoo
boys or maelstrom assuming you pick the
correct choices but that's just in one
mission some of the gangs like sixth
street and the tiger claws do absolutely
nothing with the players so they are
literally just made to be shot at there
is no way to be recruited into these
gangs or even ask them for assistance it
feels like such a waste of potential as
these games could have had a much larger
role in the game but they were just put
to be target dummies the fixers fall
into the same problem the only thing the
fixers do is call you about missions and
call you about cars them calling about
cars just feels so far off from what
they actually do in the game i feel like
cd projekt red needed some way to give
the player new vehicles so instead of
just adding car dealers they just gave
them to the fixers and it's not even
that engaging either the fixer just
randomly sends you a text of a car
nearby to which a map marker of its
location permanently stays on your map
to buy the car you just go over and hop
in and the game will take your money i'm
pretty sure all these vehicles just
exist on the map you can't steal them
from people or rob the keys from the
owner they're just cars that exist the
missions are just as bad the fixtures
will call and text you about mission
details seeing as most of these missions
are pretty much the same thing minus a
few instances there's really no point to
read the details since you already know
what to do you either kill or sneak your
way into this building than either grab
the loot rescue the person retrieve the
car etc this is all the fixers have been
reduced to you can visit them on the map
but you're only given two to three
dialogue options and that's all
something as small as giving them a
personal mission would have been great
not something from a client but an issue
that they have that you need to fix for
them the game was almost going down this
path with regina as she's the one who
wanted you to help with the cyber
psychos and she believes a cure can be
made but nothing came from it these
missions could play into the fixer's
backstory and be able to make them feel
like actual characters there's just a
clear lack of depth with both the fixers
and gangs and it makes it really hard to
care about them everything we've talked
about makes night city look great but
feel empty that city is a dystopian
setting and if you were to walk along
its streets and look around you would
notice it immediately but venture too
far off from those streets and you'll
see the real night city a place that
doesn't provide the player a way to
customize their character car or
apartment a way to store said cars and
also doesn't give the player a reason to
care about its handcrafted fixers and
gangs as rather just people in your
contact list or target dummies waiting
to be shot
night city is known as one of if not the
deadliest city in the united states so
most of your time in night city will be
spent in heated fights with gang members
and scavengers cyberpunk gives the
player a plethora of weapons and
abilities to choose from allowing you to
make a unique character that's unlike
any other at start of the game you're
given the chance to increase some of
your attributes this is the core
building blocks of your build as the
more points you put into these
attributes the more skills you can
unlock with them there are five
attributes which are body reflexes
intelligence cool and technical ability
body is centered around strength and
defense reflex will increase your
firearm damage intelligence will reward
you with more quick hack abilities and
ram slots cool is all about stealth and
technical ability is more of a
miscellaneous dump stat that is centered
around various things like looting
crafting resistances crit damage and
explosions this is where your initial
build will start however you can go
deeper from here you could go fully into
firearms and use the body stat for
health and defense then level up the
reflexes stat to get more damage skills
but if you prefer sneaking you could
replace the body stat with cool and have
a silent range build there's definitely
a lot of potential with these builds and
they can be very fun to try out and use
the game even lets you respect your
skills if you want to move things around
except it's only the skills not the
attributes so you're still stuck in the
same archetype you created but are
allowed to change the my new details of
your skill set i personally wish this
was able to be respect but the only
reason i can think of as to why is that
they didn't add this part because people
could just respect their skills if they
lack the attribute level to bypass a
door or something not only does this
sound incredibly tedious it's also the
same thing with save scumming yes being
able to save any time and anywhere does
promote safe scumming but the positives
outweigh the negatives greatly besides
the standard weaponry you can find on
enemies or in crates you can also equip
yourself with cyberware that can greatly
enhance any build you want to play with
loud and proud players can even replace
their operating system with cyberware
that doesn't even have any ram slots or
quick hacks seeing as you won't be using
them in the first place this now allows
you to gain buffs from other equipment
as for what we have cyberpunk definitely
tries its best to make combat fun by
giving the player numerous trees to pick
from allowing for tons of different
builds every playthrough however for me
i wasn't always having that much fun
with its combat i recognize this is
totally subjective as lots of people
have different tastes some people prefer
to use stealth whenever possible when i
try to never use it unless i have to so
already there's going to be some bias
towards certain archetypes so as for
stealth i will say that it was quite fun
despite me preferring a different
playstyle stealth with the introduction
of quick hacking can really change this
game in a drastic way because not only
could you never engage in combat you'll
never be close to anyone either quick
hacks will go as far as your scanner
goes and depending on your operating
system and abilities you may never even
need a weapon i do highly recommend
playing this way if you enjoy stealth as
it was really fun when things went right
blades were by far my favorite weapon to
use as with the right skills not a
single enemy is challenging the blades
are also one section of the skill tree
so once you maximize a good portion of
the stats you need you can just put
those extra points and dump them into
other stats like increased armor or
health allowing you to be pretty much
unkillable the blades were always a
blast to use however the gun play felt a
little dull there was such a large
selection of different guns that it's
quite easy to gravitate towards a
favorite weapon some of these weapons
even have special traits like smart
rounds and ricocheting bullets but due
to the game's ammo system in combination
with its skills it severely limits your
options smg's lmgs precision rifles and
ars all share the same ammo type and all
of these but lmgs are in the same skill
tree so you can have an assault rifle
smg and lmg under character you're just
going to waste all your ammo since the
game gives us three weapons to use we
need to fill those other roles which are
either shotguns pistols snipers or even
melee if we wanted to dabble into it but
due to how the skill trees are separated
you'll more than likely have three guns
with mediocre upgrades or one gun with
incredible upgrades and the other two
with next to nothing and while it's not
the end-all be-all of this game the
upgrades are very important as they do
make your weapons stronger this also
becomes more of a problem later when you
have to change weapons the same weapon
you're currently using could be swapped
for the same one since the enemy that
died was higher than you thus making
that gun automatically better while this
example is not as bad it becomes a
problem when you have to swap a weapon
that you didn't want to use but now need
to use because its stats are just better
this also goes for your armor as well
this game is one where you need to
prioritize your stats or your fashion as
there's no way to change the look of the
armor and keep its stats the very last
part of its gameplay though is its
crafting and to be completely honest
with you i've never touched crafting in
this game i find it extremely
unnecessary crafting is nice if you want
to make more grenades health inhalers or
even make upgraded versions of legendary
gear but i never needed to most of my
armor and weapons were getting
outclassed as i ranked up so there was
no point in spending all this time and
money on upgrade components when they
would just get outmatched by any weapon
to add to this i also never ran out of
inhalers or grenades i could definitely
see some use out of it on higher
difficulties when you need a specific
health booster to heal but i just never
ran out assuming you loot enough of the
bodies in each area you'll have more
than enough gear to go around that
crafting was just an afterthought to me
cyberpunk's gameplay variety is very fun
and does allow for lots of creativity
when it comes to builds you want it
allows for endless possibilities and
that is a very important feature for a
game like this but while its blades and
stealth were fun the gun play in the
game just felt a bit confusing as it
seems to encourage using a diverse
arsenal of weapons but it also hinders
the potential of said weapons by making
the ammo the same for most of its guns
so far i've definitely been critical of
this game so it's time to change that as
cyberpunk's biggest strength is in its
side quests cyberpunk has somewhere
between 70 to 80 sidequests the player
can complete and just about all of them
are perfect most of these weren't just
simple quests that could be finished in
a few minutes but rather multi-stage
experiences that involved complex moral
conundrums that show the player a more
sinister side to the city i won't be
going over every quest in this video as
there's too many to go over so i'll just
talk about a few of my personal
favorites our first quest is one that is
deeply disturbing randomly while strong
through night city you may get a call
from wakako about a job when we arrive
at the location the client bill
jablonski talks to us about wanting to
kill a specific person bill says this
guy josh is a murderer we discover that
josh murdered bill's wife and while he
was put on death row for his actions he
was able to get out of it from the
details we get from bill this job may
not go as planned as we have very little
info on who josh is riding with or and
whether or not they're considered a
threat we eventually find the van that
he's in and chase them near an underpass
until they crash bill gets out of the
car and is about to start shooting until
he's put down by the cop that was
driving assuming you're quick enough you
can actually shoot the cop and josh
which ends the quest okaka will pay you
for your trouble and you'll go on your
way without even knowing that there's a
quest tied to this if you let bill get
shot josh will vouch for your safety and
instead ask you to accompany him on his
journey it's a strange request but
obviously we have to accept to continue
already i love the way this mission
starts as you can go an entire
playthrough without ever seeing the full
story of it wakako even drops hints
about this as she asks via what he
thought about it why would she ever
bother bringing that part up even if
this was something she says all the time
from our perspective what was there to
understand we killed a murderer and we
got paid it's a brilliant way of telling
the player that there might be more
going on here this part of the quest was
also really well written as when you
talk to josh he refuses to elaborate on
anything until you get in the vehicle so
you rather say no when live your life
wondering what he wants or give in and
say yes you can see what's going on josh
is a murderer on death row as told to us
by bill the reason he escaped his death
was that he claimed to have found god
during his time in jail this isn't the
exact reason why but it's more related
to the characters in the car with us the
cop vasquez is the guard and he's there
to make sure josh doesn't run off but
rachel is from a media company who's
planning on filming a documentary about
him in fact we already know what that
documentary is as we can see it
plastered all over night city josh also
lets us know that we're going to see
someone today which is why we're
traveling in the car together the person
we meet is a woman named zuleka and it's
at this table where we discover the
whole truth josh murdered zuleika's
brother and was receiving letters from
her while he was in jail zuleika came to
accept and forgive josh for what he did
despite how traumatic this must have
been for her in the family furthermore
we find out that when josh claimed to
have found god in prison a braindance
studio the one rachel works for wanted
to make a video out of it and josh took
up their offer so that his death can be
used to show others that redemption is
possible from what it sounds like it
seems that josh wants to do some good in
his life and the media studio definitely
wants to explode him for profit the
actions of one will help achieve the
other person's goals so they agreed to
work together after this discovery we
see julia's mom who's not as happy as
zuleika is to see josh in her home again
she kicks both of us out and then we
head to a nearby restaurant for some
quick food this ends the quest for now
until we get a call a couple days later
where we can continue this was such a
fantastic idea for the quest and the
amount of options we are given is
incredible after our visit with zuleika
rachel will pull us aside and talk about
josh she mentions how he's very valuable
to the company and it's because of his
authenticity he's not putting on some
act for the braindance he genuinely
believes his crucifixion can change the
world it's because of this that prompts
rachel to bring us aside where she tells
us to leave if we keep talking to josh
we might screw up the job and get him to
question his decision so she's trying to
avoid that entirely by paying us double
the original amount if we leave this
section also brings up a good point and
it's that this mission gives us numerous
times to just leave and drop the quest
i'm unsure if it's because of the heavy
subject matter within the quest but we
can leave five different times
throughout these missions one is before
we get in the van another while we are
in the van and learn about him in his
heavenly journey the third after we
discover the truth about his crucifixion
the fourth being here with rachel and
the fifth one during the last mission
it's nice that the game is letting the
player leave if things get too heavy
it's a nice way of not forcing the
player to do something they might not
want to do going back to the mission the
reason there is another quest is because
josh is second guessing his decisions
here's where we can do one of many
things no matter what happens josh will
be crucified but we can either help nail
him to the cross not help him but watch
or just leave this choice and other
dialogue choices throughout the missions
will affect the overall quality of the
db and in turn also affect our pay if we
say too many things to josh that make
him quest in his decision we'll get paid
less as the db wasn't as authentic but
if we avoid saying any of these options
we can get the most pay from it this
interaction at the end is incredibly
hard to watch as the nailing of his
wrist and legs is right in front of you
my original decision was to help nail
him to the cross as i believe that while
i didn't want him to go through with it
i should at least honor his dying wish
which was to be by his side for the
whole event by the way this quest does
not end until he dies so you must sit
and watch in real time as he slowly
loses consciousness this whole thing
lasts a full minute and is one of the
longest minutes of my life everything
about this quest was just so real there
were no gimmicks involved in this quest
and cd projekt red wanted there to be
none they wanted you to sit through the
entire process no matter how dark this
got the quest left the player with lots
of choices and this is truly a great
showcase of the writer's talent to
create a story that seems to have an
element of choice it's one quest that
has stuck with me for the past year and
one i probably won't ever forget
everything about this was just so
enthralling but terrifying i was
constantly waiting to see where this
quest would go but i was also worried
what would happen by the end the fact
that this quest has no characters
relevant to the main story and are only
seen during this quest just shows how
good this really is i never needed a
character from the main story or a plot
revolving around the main story to be
good it was just a stand-alone quest
with one of the best stories i've ever
seen our next quest is one that is also
deeply disturbing but in a different
context just like before we get a call
from a random person during our
playthrough this person is elizabeth
perales and she wants us to meet with
her and her husband jeff it sounds like
i'm about to bring up the paralysis
questline which i will very soon but i
want to focus on the other character
involved being river ward river is only
slightly involved with the perales
questline as the original job is to
investigate the death of lucius ryan the
recently deceased mayor of night city
river is important as he was spotted in
the brain dance so we contact him and
ask if we can work together to solve the
case this part isn't too important but
the quest after it is river will once
again call us out of the blue and when
we arrive he will show us a recent news
feed the feat shows the cops doing a
routine inspection of a car until the
cops realize that the person in the car
is a known serial killer he's then
subdued by police and we see the
passenger was dead prior to the police's
arrival the reason river shows us this
video is because his nephew randy had
disappeared recently and that kid was
wearing randy's shoes so he suspects
this killer anthony had something to do
with his kidnapping river takes us to a
place where anthony used to be held this
place has some unique technology that
can create bds from dreams by forcing
them to think of specific things in
their life i'm not really sure how this
works but it's not too necessary we're
trying to get anthony to dream of past
events in his life so that he can maybe
give us a clue to where he took randy
but after being caught sneaking in and a
long conversation this lady that we
argue with eventually agrees although
very reluctantly to find these memories
we need to search randy's room for clues
where we find an email chain between the
two we also see a deeply disturbing
video of this farmer with his cows and
regardless of the context it doesn't
take away this eerie feeling that comes
with it after talking with the employee
from earlier in the mission we can
compile a brain dance and see even more
disturbing stuff about anthony's
childhood his dad forced him to help her
on the farm and since anthony was a kid
at the time he obviously didn't know too
much about farming so he was bound to
make mistakes and whenever he did his
father would ridicule him for it he also
had so much pent-up anger from his dad
that he even lashed out and killed his
mom shortly after this the father's
business would fail and due to this
failure he would kill himself so now
anthony was an orphan with seemingly no
friends or support system to manage his
problems the only thing that kept him
calm was that cartoon of the farmer
earlier he became so fascinated with the
farm and that cartoon that he continued
his dad's work of running the farm but
instead of using cows he used people
they were all hooked up to these giant
machines that pumped various chemicals
and gases into their lungs through the
brain dance we managed to discover where
the farm is and after breaking inside we
can rescue randy and all the others that
managed to survive this just like the
quest with josh was such a memorable
experience it was a shocking and
horrifying investigation where the
outcome was never certain it was never
clear if randy was actually going to
survive or not and that added some
urgency and tension to this quest
something i discovered recently was that
you can actually fail this quest if you
don't get enough evidence during the
brain dance we have to choose between
two farms and if you choose the wrong
one then randy dies i'm honestly
surprised this was an option but this
just adds another layer of urgency as
randy could actually die if we choose
wrong detective quests in many games are
always really intriguing especially when
they play into the world of the game and
with a game like cyberpunk where the
world is technologically advanced
anything can happen and i think that's a
big reason why this was so fun we truly
didn't know how the cyberware and
technology of night city would have a
hand in this quest structure and the way
it was utilized was really impressive
while river's questline was shorter than
most of the multi-stage quests in this
game it has by far one of the most
memorable moments due to its disturbing
content our last quest is once again
related to the previous interaction but
this time we'll talk about the other
side of it jefferson perales holds the
title for the greatest side quest in the
entire game it is not only a fantastic
quest with an incredible story but it is
so compelling that judging from the
comments on my previous video about it
many people wanted this developed into a
full dlc the quest line originally is
quite average and seems to exist just so
that the player can be introduced to
river however a couple days after
completing the original quest you'll
receive another message from jeff's wife
elizabeth the couple had a break-in and
they want to know who and why seeing as
jeff is in the running for mayor there's
a lot this investigation could bring up
as is possible that someone is targeting
him because he's rich or the person he's
running against is trying to eliminate
him the two of them want us to look into
it since we already unraveled the
mystery of the mayor's death plus they
already tried their private security
firm and they came up with nothing the
only details we can get from jeff is
that someone ended up breaking in when
he noticed he reached for his gun and
possibly shot the intruder before
passing out and waking up the next
morning with a terrible headache this
quest provides the player with an
immense amount of freedom as while
elizabeth does show you the penthouse
you can get a lay of the land she never
explicitly tells you what to search for
it's all on you to find the clues
furthermore some clues like this screen
can't be turned on unless you spec in a
technical ability and some doors won't
open without enough points in the body
tree obviously the game isn't going to
make the players spec into a specific
tree to complete the quest as that would
be quite frustrating but they do give
the players more optional clues if the
player has the proper skills everything
we investigate also comes with a bit of
dialogue that not only gives us more
hints about the investigation but also
further develops the couple as
characters by investigating the table
elizabeth will tell us about the
election process like how they're paying
for everything out of pocket and because
of how much work there is to do they
just order pizza most days as is too
hard to cook it's just genuine fantastic
storytelling as it's making the powerful
rich people seem like common folk but
also making these fictional characters
seem real and fully developed we
eventually begin to uncover the story of
the break-in as we see some emails from
the private security firm jeff had hired
and in one of these emails is a code to
a room this is already quite suspicious
since the room is only accessible via a
hidden door that the couple had no idea
existed however continuing on we
understand the full story once we read
the other emails that talk about one of
its members being shot by target alpha
this explains the bandages inside the
room but this also connects the entire
story that jeff is target alpha and the
security firm has been spying on them
the entire time after some further
investigation we noticed a satellite
dish on the roof and a comms tower
implying that the security team is
nearby we chase down the van and after
killing all the enemies we try to get
the data from the van until it's wiped
by an external source from what we saw
though it seems like they have brain
scan data on the couple and are using
neural links to implant new memories
into them this connects to one of the
clues we discovered earlier which is the
couple's wedding photo when
investigating this photo elizabeth will
say that she ordered blue roses for the
wedding despite the picture clearly
having red roses the last thing we get
to see before were shot out of the van
is that other people have been infected
with new memories too these people
aren't important but it's showing us
that jeff isn't a unique case they're
doing this to anybody regardless of
gender ethnicity or income we relay the
information to elizabeth who offers to
discuss the matter in private the game
isn't done with twists as we discovered
that elizabeth knew about these changes
in jeff his personality had changed
overnight and it almost felt like he was
a completely different person elizabeth
even noticed herself changing and once
it started getting worse she was in such
a total state of panic that she didn't
even know if she could trust her own
judgment she also got a call from
someone in a garbled voice telling her
that her family's safety and happiness
could end real soon if she attempts to
figure out the truth this presents the
player with an interesting dilemma as we
have the option to tell jefferson about
this discovery if we tell him we could
possibly ruin the lives of the couple
but it allows jeff to know the truth or
we can keep it a secret and never tell
him it's got its own set of moral
choices as some may argue that the
safety of the family is more important
but some could also argue that jeff has
a right to know what's going on however
what's more important is what happens in
the quest this quest was the start of a
massive community theory based around a
group called alpha centauri it's quite a
complex theory so if you want to know
everything you can check out my video on
it but to give you the short version
there was something very sinister
happening in this game that could
possibly affect all the citizens within
its walls if they get their way when we
approach jeff during the final part of
the quest we short circuit temporarily
as a garbled voice talks to us it's
quite possible that this was the same
garbled voice that elizabeth heard on
top of this nearby watching over our
discussion is mr blue eyes the same one
from the rogue ending he's not here
before the meeting and he leaves the
moment we're finished so that pretty
much confirms that he's only here
because of our discussion with jeff the
theory doesn't stop here as we have even
more clues as at some random point in
the game we get a call from sandra
dorsett which is the girl we saved from
the intro she needs our help getting
back a data bank that was stolen from
her if we go against her wishes and read
the shard we see that this operation
carpe noctum is eerily similar to what's
going on with the paralyzes furthermore
mr blue eyes also has this very unique
ring on his finger it's also very
similar to the ones worn by big joe
arthur jenkins jeff perales gary the
prophet and anders hellman they're all
slightly different in color in design
which may imply that they're either
marked by the organization behind the
brain scans or employed by them in some
way it's possible that mr blue eyes is
trying to further this organization's
agenda by having v attack the crystal
palace which we see in the ending this
is why this whole theory is so
compelling because most of these
characters are relevant to some of the
game's endings so it leaves this
open-ended question about what's really
going on it's without a doubt the best
side quest in the entire game and by far
one of the best waves i've seen a theory
be developed as it serves as a blueprint
for how an engaging quest should be one
thing you may have noticed is that all
the quests that i brought up today have
the story at the forefront there was
little to no combat in any of these
quests and i hope the reception and
positivity these quests received from
the community tells cd projekt red they
don't have to base the entire game
around combat not everything is about
shooting people and collecting loot
that's why the side activities were so
boring as it all felt repetitive but
with these i never felt bored and in
fact i was more engaged in the game than
ever obviously not every quest is like
this and many of them still have lots of
combat involved in them but regardless
of combat or not a majority of cyberpunk
side quests are well written and
incredibly captivating they're without a
doubt cyberpunk's biggest strength and i
hope they continue to lean heavily into
this content in a future dlc
keeping with the theme of positivity
let's end the video on a high note and
talk about its story i think this story
is fantastic is it the best narrative
i've ever seen absolutely not but just
by playing this game you can tell that
there's lots of passion put into it
furthermore the themes within the game
are quite thought-provoking and if a
game can make me think about its story
even after finishing it then it
succeeded cyberpunk is a story about the
race to immortality other ritual
continued reign over the poor forever
but it's also a story about one specific
murk who wants to make it to the top
however due to certain choices and
actions throughout their journey that
dream of theirs will come crashing down
the game is split into three acts act
one is before meeting johnny act three
is the ending and act two is everything
in between act one on a first
playthrough is really exciting it's the
beginning of a new game so you're
eagerly waiting for what comes next
after completing the life path we get a
six month time lapse of v and jackie's
life until we're given control again and
are about to start a job i have an
obvious issue with that time lapse that
many of you will agree with but i'll get
back to that later the first job is
quite basic and is more to get you
familiar with all the game's mechanics
after this mission is where things start
to evolve as we are notified that the
police are shutting down the watson
district the game locks us out of the
other districts until the first act is
over but it still gives us all the
content within the district so it's a
nice way to ease the player into the
game's side activities but not overwhelm
them by unlocking everything we're still
not done with the tutorials as we're
introduced to the ripper doc clinics and
then are given a quest with a great deal
of choices cd projekt red did an
incredible job making the first act as i
was able to see everything the game had
to offer but was also only allowed to go
within the first district so that i
never felt lost trying to explore the
whole map that mission i previously
mentioned is quite impressive and gives
the player lots of freedom the main goal
of the mission is to obtain this
flathead bot from the gang maelstrom
dexter deshawn the one who gives us the
job has already paid for it but never
got the bot and is hoping we can handle
that issue while maelstrom seems like
the only people involved in the quest
there's also a woman named meredith
stout who's involved there is an
optional objective to call and meet with
her which can potentially lead to a deal
the other person with her is andrew
gilchrist who is also important so now
we have three different people that can
be affected by our choices all the
options lead into two main branches we
can either resolve things peacefully
with maelstrom or slaughter everyone in
the building then because of this choice
and other choices i'll get to shortly
we'll either involve gilchrist or stout
meeting us at the entrance firstly when
we meet with maelstrom we can pay for
the flathead in a few ways either buying
it with our own money a credit chip that
style gave to us or just shooting
maelstrom and taking it ourselves this
credit chip leads to other options as
the chip that style gave us was infected
we can either leave the virus which will
make us hostile to maelstrom or if we
wipe out the virus then tell brick about
it we can work with him to defeat
militech pretty much any option that
forces us to shoot militech ends with
gilchrist at the end of the quest and
any option that makes maelstrom our
target will have stout at the end of the
quest these are just about every option
involved in this quest and it really
allows for that feeling of freedom you
have so many options and so many options
within options that it's overwhelming to
piece all them together it's just
upsetting that as we continue most of
the game it's quite linear from here
after doing all the tasks that dexter
has assigned us he meets with us to
discuss the real reason we did all this
prep work at a building called kampeki
plaza there is a penthouse owned by yori
nobu arasaka the son of saburo arasaka
apparently in this room there is a
device called the biochip and is
extremely expensive our client evelyn
parker who we met previously wants this
biochip this is where we get introduced
to the brain dances of cyberpunk end
once again more on those in a moment
jackie and v's job is to infiltrate the
building sneak into yori noble's room
and steal the chip everything goes
completely backwards as yorinubu comes
back to his room and has a meeting with
saburo it continues to go even further
south as he strangles his own father and
puts the building in lockdown the two
used the opportunity to escape until
their escape attempt ruined the case the
biochip was in and it needs to be put
into someone's head for it to maintain
the temperature despite both of them
being injured they managed to make it
downstairs and escape the plaza until
jackie succumbs to his wounds and dies
so
where to begin firstly this act was a
roller coaster of emotions in a good way
it was a really well made first act
although one of my biggest complaints is
this axe length even on repeat
playthroughs assuming you skipped
through all the dialogue this will take
about 2 hours i don't consider the game
to start until act 2 is that's when
everything is open and available to the
player without any restriction this act
is actually what stops me from playing
the game sometimes since i know i need
to get through this incredibly long act
before i can actually explore night city
what definitely doesn't help is that
long brain dance introduction too on
your first playthrough the braindances
were great but now knowing i have to go
through them again on another
playthrough is just exhausting this is
what makes this act so hard to talk
about running through this on your first
playthrough is wonderful and i have no
issues with it but on future
playthroughs it starts to become really
tedious while this does bother me it is
really situational as not everyone will
feel the same about the first act as i
do and some people may not even play the
game for another playthrough regardless
what's more important is jackie i've
come to the conclusion that cd projekt
red did not care about jackie as they
wanted the player to focus more on
johnny than they did jackie which is
quite ironic considering more people
like jackie the reason i say this is
because of the time lapse from earlier
and his death the less time we spend
with jackie the less opportunities we
have to build a relationship with him i
would have much rather preferred the
game just make me do these missions with
jackie rather than just showing us a
time lapse because i stopped caring we
aren't building that connection together
through our jobs and we're not feeling
like an actual team we aren't helping
one another during combat engagements or
just working together the intro is a
really good example is you and jackie
can work together to defeat the guy with
the machine gun by being a distraction
while jackie tackles him you feel like a
fully functioning team that is working
together to achieve a goal everything
else you do with him doesn't feel like
this the only times we join him are when
we buy the flathead and when we steal
the biochip but everything is done by
yourself you control the decisions of
the maelstrom conflict and you control
the flathead so you're able to get
inside yorinobu's room he just feels
like a companion that tags along and
will do what you do and go where you go
he isn't given an opportunity to shine
on his own his death also bothers me
greatly because this had zero impact on
me i sound like a heartless person but
it's not because i had no attachment to
jackie it's because cd projekt red
spoiled this in a trailer a year before
the game's launch in their e3 2019
trailer jackie and v escape a building
and use the delamane taxi service to
drive away then jackie shortly dies
after just like in game this trailer
shows us jackie and says his name which
means this person who may or may not be
in the game is jackie they didn't even
try to hide his haircut or face as he
looks exactly like the way he does in
game so prepare for the game i watched
most of the trailers again like the 48
minute gameplay demo and this cinematic
trailer because i thought it looked
really nice so imagine my face when i
found out that this jackie person is in
fact a real character in the game there
was still some hope in my mind that we
could maybe save him or he wouldn't have
been shot at all but that started coming
true when i noticed him limping with a
bullet wound in his stomach if you're
going to make me care about a character
don't show them dying in a trailer prior
to the game's release if jackie's death
managed to surprise you then i'm glad as
the way this was shown to the player and
how the next interaction starts with
that slow faded intro and low monotone
voice of v was really well done but it
was completely ruined for me as i saw it
coming way earlier than i should have
before we enter act 2 we see v approach
the note motel to meet dex who then
shoots him for screwing up the job we
then finally get introduced to johnny
silverhand and get to see how the
arasaka tower was destroyed 50 years ago
it's a nice introduction it really
highlights how much of a [ __ ] johnny
can be as instead of just dropping the
bomb and leaving he needed to complete
another personal mission of his which is
how he got killed this is where the big
plot twist of the game starts as it's
discovered that v will die within a few
weeks before jackie died he took the
biochip out of his head and gave it to v
when dex killed v the nanites and the
biochip were working on repairing his
brain but since he wasn't fully brain
dead yet the nanites could only repair
part of his brain which is why johnny
and v can co-exist the problem is that
this isn't supposed to happen is either
v or johnny not both which is why v is
slowly dying as the biochip is eating
away at his central nervous system these
main goal now has changed as instead of
making it to the top he's now
desperately trying to save his own life
this was a really nice plot change and a
nice way of putting it into perspective
of how the fear of immortality can
change you can you imagine how it must
feel to hear someone say you have weeks
to live when the day prior your death
wasn't even on your mind and you'd
figured you just die of old age all
those things you wanted to accomplish or
do in life won't ever be finished as
your life expectancy has been
drastically reduced in the blink of an
eye cd projekt red really wanted to
capture the desperation and fear of
something like this and i think they
nailed it act 2 starts and ends really
strong as we get introduced to johnny
silverhand it's very apparent from the
very first conversation they have that
the two are bitter enemies and want
nothing to do with one another v wants
johnny out so that he can live and
johnny wants to take over control of v
so that he can get revenge on arasaka
again the game allows you to play into
this as you can cut conversations with
him short by taking your prescribed
pills or just outright leaving it was
nice that the devs had given you the
option to truly express how you feel
about johnny through gameplay however i
don't think johnny is a bad person
kinda yes he's still an [ __ ] who
killed a ton of innocent people and his
ego never really goes away throughout
the game but at least between him and v
things do change between the two johnny
gets more sentimental and calm in the
later parts of the game and he comes to
accept the fact that he can't change the
world and he's just a ghost in v's head
v is also dealing with this frustration
as the entirety of act 2 is about
searching for a cure he tries to find
evelyn to see if she has any info on the
chip and this doesn't work but thanks to
some braindance v ends up working with
the voodoo boys but that didn't work
either he even captures the creator of
the chip and not even he can help him
these failures aren't just affecting v
it's affecting us too we're like
detectives trying to find new leads but
every single one we find leads to a dead
end and we're running out of options the
two of them are struggling together and
eventually learn to accept the other and
are willing to help one another to
complete their goal the two by the end
of the game have seemingly exhausted
every option possible except one as the
only one that has shown any promise is
hanako arasaka the sister of yorinobu
thanks to her interrogation with helman
v is able to download the blueprints of
the biochip and uses this data to strike
a deal with hanukkah the start of act 2
sees v being rescued by takamura the
same one who guards saburo arasaka
takamura is the only one who believes
that yuri nobu murdered saburo sakamura
is also on the run as yuri nobu betrayed
him so he wants to get back at your
renobu and find justice for saburo so
takamura works with v to discuss each
other's plans and eventually agree to
meet with hanako takamura wants to meet
with her to prove that yorinobu is a
killer envy wants to meet with her to
see if she can get him access to a place
called mikoshi mikoshi is the only
reason that johnny is alive and in our
head after blowing up arasaka tower they
stored his soul on a data drive and kept
it in this place called mikoshi this
place holds other people who signed up
for the secure your soul program
originally it was used for people to
talk to the dead after they had already
passed but there was a newer version of
this tech made and it's the one that's
in our head instead of someone being a
hologram after death they can take over
a person's body so they can continue to
live just be in the body of another
person this would then allow that person
to be immortal v needs to use mikoshi's
access point so that he can split
himself and johnny so that he doesn't
die v then discovers that mikoshi is
deep in arasaka tower so we know where
to go but we don't know how to get
inside the game then provides us with
four ways to accomplish this and are
considered the game's four endings our
first option is v working with hanako so
that they can bring down yorinobu
arasaka and bring sabro back into power
once again after this happens its top
scientists will help v with the chip
instead of that route we can either have
pam and the aldo caldos join us and
break into the tower or have johnny take
over our body and instead of those two
it's now rogue and wayland if none of
these satisfy the player they can always
take the easy route and commit suicide
the player is given many choices and the
way they set the scene was brilliant as
it's just you on a rooftop looking at
night city trying to make your final
decision the game lets you sit here as
long as you need so you never need to
feel rushed about your final choice cd
projekt red wants you to consider
everything you've gone through and
everything you felt throughout the game
and use those emotions and feelings to
make a decision each ending invokes
something throughout its time and it
gets the player thinking about their
decision what really hits the hardest is
the moment when you discover that every
ending ends in your death the biochip
has progressed so far that survival is
not possible anymore it invoked a
feeling in me that i haven't experienced
in many games that feeling being that
everything i did was completely useless
we were doomed from the beginning and it
was all for nothing that's what makes
these endings so great and this decision
has an impact on other people's lives
not just your own if you join arasaka
then we discovered that they used you as
a test on me and were able to replicate
the process allowing saburo to live in
yorinobu's body zeburo is no longer
bound by the body and can simply take
over a new one when the current one he's
using has passed in our desperate
attempt to help ourselves we let the
biggest corporation in the world learn
the secret to immortality if we do the
suicide ending then we affect everyone
that we've ever met it's the easy way
out and the least bloody option but
what's the point of going through all
this work just to give up at the very
end the final two decisions are not just
about johnny and v's relationship but
our relationship with johnny v is
destined to die within six months so we
either keep our body and say goodbye to
johnny or have johnny take our body
instead according to all tv's own body
sees him as an intruder now and we are
left with a decision let v keep the body
and live out his life for the next few
months until he dies or give it to
johnny who can live much longer and also
be able to experience a new life again
not bound by his rocker boy persona it's
a tough decision of sacrificing your
life for a friend or continue to live
but also having to say goodbye to yet
another friend cyberpunk's ending was
fantastic and while it was very sad that
nothing we did truly mattered in the end
the way the story was told was extremely
well done as for my final thoughts on
the game
cyberpunk is always going to be a
phenomenon of the gaming industry never
have i seen a game gather so much hype
and also simultaneously let everyone
down at the same time as i said before
cyberpunk isn't a good game but it's
also not a bad game either its gangs and
fixers feel underdeveloped its technical
issues are still very prevalent today
and some of its systems like crafting
inside activities are just boring dull
and useless however if you want to play
the game for its story then you will not
be sorry its attention to detail within
its open world makes it one of the most
gorgeous settings i've stepped foot in
and its side quest and story are worth
buying the game for just that alone
cyberpunk to me has always been a
complicated game to discuss because it
wasn't overwhelmingly good or bad to me
it was just perfectly average but with
some time and hope this game could maybe
become what it was originally intended
to be
thank you all for watching today's video
if you enjoyed then leave a like and
consider subscribing for more content
like this if you want to check out a
video similar in style to this then i
recommend my full analysis on the halo
series or prey both are quite long but
if you've made it this far in the video
that shouldn't matter and you don't need
to watch those videos in one sitting of
course you can always watch all the lore
videos i made back then on cyberpunk as
some of the content discussed in this
video had full videos dedicated to it
like the side quests and cyber psychosis
regardless thank you for making it to
the end and to my returning viewers i
thank you for coming back
take care everyone
goodbye
[Music]
so
[Music]